[Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  a guard a senior  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  this night we are excited to present  Isaiah Stewart with an honorary Dean  Jersey commemorating his selection to  the 2019 McDonald's all-american games I  say congratulations on achieving your  dream of becoming a McDonald's all  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]